one of our most faithful fans Andres
came to visit us a few months ago
bringing us all sorts of chemical
goodies including a couple of Chinese
ping-pong balls which he said burnt
really well and of course anything that
burns is irresistible to neil our
technician the interesting thing about
this is that although burning a
ping-pong ball is a fun experiment it
has quite an interesting lesson about
many chemical experiments I've never
tried to burn a ping-pong ball and I
don't even know if they're all made from
the same material but these particular
ones appear to be made out of cellulose
nitrate or something very similar
cellulose nitrate is cellulose from
plant material that has been treated
with nitric acid and is very similar to
gun cotton the explosive that we've made
the video about before
oh that's pretty impressive
and because it contains a nitrate group
nitrogen oxygen it has available oxygen
within the structure to help it burn and
nitrogen atoms which can combine to
release heat when it forms n2 nitrogen
gas it is also useful because you can
easily mold it into smooth shapes like a
ping-pong ball
the reason why I think this experiments
really interesting is because it
combines both physics and chemistry in
chemistry the underlying reaction will
always be the same when you burn the
ball it is going to turn into co2 water
and nitrogen gas but the interesting
thing is that as a chemist you have to
be able to distinguish between what is
the underlying chemistry and what is the
chance physics and in Neil's experiment
we've got a beautiful demonstration of
that essentially he took the two balls
one after the other and put a gas torch
to it so they caught fire ostensibly the
experiments were identical but in detail
of course they're not
because he may have touched the torch on
the slightly different part on the ball
slightly lower or slightly higher
because it's in a fume cupboard the wind
might have been blowing slightly
differently on the two occasions so what
happens is the way that the flame
spreads on the balls are quite different
if you were doing the experiment you
might say well it's completely
irreproducible you don't get the same
result twice but the chemical result is
the same
you still get co2 water and steam and
nitrogen but the way the flame spreads
is different and the first one that was
done the the ball melted and this little
flaming bit fell down the other one
burnt almost completely away with a
looked a bit like a flaming space
capsule or something like that with the
flames coming out one side and all that
was left was really a tiny tiny little
bit one really has to become almost
romantic looking at the flames because
the way the flame spreads is really
beautiful especially when it is slowed
down you can see the swirling of the
flame and how it spreads and sometimes
scientists can be a bit analytical and
they forget just how beautiful some of
the things are that we observe in the
lab brady gets really cross he says i
bring my family into every video but i
think this time I have a real excuse
because the ping-pong balls which I
knees and ping pong is a fantastically
popular game in China and my mother's
cousin eivol Montagu who died many years
ago and you can see his picture here is
the person who introduced ping pong as a
national sport into China
he wrote the rules for international
ping pong
and there's recently in a book published
about him which talks about how
ping-pong became important in the
diplomacy between China and the United
States it was all due to my mother's
cousin even want to go so there is a
connection